I have a saying that I've come to really
believe in and it's very simply never
allow your inability to do everything to
undermine your determination to do
something we live in a world where it's
almost impossible to bring about the
transformations that you desire in a
large setting in a single lifetime or to
do those things alone and you almost
have to surrender to that understanding
but yet work as if you could transform
the world have that kind of passion
still animate you and so it's definitely
difficult it was there was definitely
times in my career that I've felt a
sense of overwhelm about the challenges
but I think the more that I learned
about how incapable I was the more it
turned on to me this understanding that
I can therefore manifest my strength one
thought once I have that confession to
myself that I'm not Superman or I don't
possess a magic wand to fix all this it
suddenly makes you feel very dependent
in a empowering way and I you know I
went through these periods of my life
where I'd be had these AHA cycle oh wait
a minute I don't have to do it all
myself in fact I can find coalition's
with others that we can do more in fact
I found out that the uncommon
coalition's create uncommon change and
probably one of the best things times
has happened to me was at a time where I
really was broken where I felt the
weakest the most vulnerable the
beginning of my political career and I
just been elected to the City Council
and a faced opposition like I never
imagined and a mayor that was abusing me
I felt was abusing me in pretty
significant ways from my car getting
ticketed all the time to even it coming
out in the papers that my phones were
being tapped I couldn't get anything
passed in the legislature and the
pressure on me was mounting to do
something about the problems in the war
and I represented and I had this
breaking point where I actually was very
ugly towards a leader in my community
who called for me for help and I ended
up being incredibly disrespectful to
them letting out anger that had been
building up in frustration and building
but thanks to the wisdom of another
person who in a very funny way said she
had presented herself as a ship that
solutions to my problems and I said well
what's the big answer and she said well
I've got and you know she's what's the
big answer and she goes to me you should
do I'm like yeah she says you should do
something and I'm like what she was just
do something about it just just do
something you don't have to solve the
whole thing I think was her point and I
ended up doing something radically
beyond what I imagined you know and by
the way this idea of cynicism about the
challenges is a toxic mental and
spiritual state because it undermines
your creativity it inhibits your ability
to see faint possibility amidst glaring
challenges and once you turn yourself
into an agent of creativity and
positivity despite the wretchedness of
whatever reality you're facing you have
breakthroughs and so what I decided to
do was to pitch a tent in this very
troubled projects or that was calling me
for help and just announced the world
that I was going to go on a hunger
strike until we did something about the
problems that were there and amazingly
thousands of people came out to the tent
to lend a hand and before you knew it we
were running activities for kids had job
fairs we had health trucks coming out
from hospitals to do health screenings
for defense we made some change now do
we solve all the problems no but that
energy that was unleashed by these folks
coming together black white Latino Asian
Muslim leaders Jewish leaders Christian
leaders atheists so many people came to
that community that for a period of time
we were able to make a big difference in
the reality and it was just a lesson to
me that you know individually were were
so we're beautiful people were so weak I
always say we're like snowflakes so
fragile but if you've been in a blizzard
in in the Northeast you know that when
those snowflakes fragile small come
together they can make a big impact and
the that's that's what I've learned one
of the most important lessons I've
learned in my journey